you
you
you
yo its carry the urine askgaryvee show
with Adam Braun what's your name
you kidding me man not joking no my name
is CJ Reynolds I see too much build-up
yet born and raised
you know I'm playground right I love it
CJ how are you I'm doing great man I'm
sitting here watching your feed not
waiting for the next question we done so
I didn't know if you were going to call
well guess what you wanted to come in
the room to ask me for something real
quick all right in ten seconds you got
if you're ready with your time on nine
but here's my question okay uh I have
Judas ami that I teach you much about
this you do all voice cool and we're
talking like inner-city Philadelphia and
you know I'm gonna show them this feed
and what I would love to show them is
you giving them some advice as to what
to do after high school
if they don't want to go to college
because coming from me it's like yeah
you're a teacher you're the teacher over
and over again I'm a teacher I teach
ninth I teach my free literature I
actually um I hit you up on Twitter a
while ago when you were looking for
schools to come action yeah yep do we
have a uncle that I love about good okay
so so what could you speak to my
students they kind of give them
something to you know that they're not
get here to me but they're they know who
you are we watch your videos in class um
they keep asking me like they're like uh
you know like so like I'm always given
them your information and telling them
what what I think you would say but I
would love for you to speak to them
directly if you could I could now like
give me help me a little bit here
because the truth is let's start from
the top know a lot of hi guys has been
have been literally punched in them out
many times in their lives and so it's
about like helping them to see that
there's visitors kind of more to
themselves or that there's they have
more to offer than um you know they kind
of been beaten down already and some
guys seem a little bit uh do they have
the chip on her shoulder that somebody
owes them something because it was
[ __ ] up or do they have no self-esteem
because everybody told them they can't
win both you know what
suppose that in Medellin we're talking
about buoy so it's always cool where you
know 90% of my guys don't have a dad at
home which yes which literally make my
job easier because you know you're a guy
that shows up every day help kids that
you love them and that your see them and
that they're not invisible
I run a special question if I paint for
the bus like I know schools are [ __ ]
up so they can't take it in but if I pay
for the bus
can you bring like eight or nine of them
up here and hang with me for an hour
let's take over I'm gonna do some
[ __ ] contest Reynolds do it on the
[ __ ] you've got to do to get picked
eight or nine of them bring them up here
we'll jam with them we'll film that and
then you can use it guys identified as
being something that like I think here
the dialog about and also that like
could use the talk also right and I'm
not saying like you're like soldiers
John let me rewrite moonlight I know
some groups to reason like I saw the
guys like Natalie looks like everyone's
got that all of you have something
different going on I just think is the
chance of a lifetime
Reynolds I can't wait to [ __ ] see you
you better get your ass here soon
the seasons almost over vet then I'm
some soon [ __ ] yeah I'll see you next
week if I get out see ya
[Music]
we're on our way up now for leaving on
our way here we go to your seat
[Music]
all right we made it to New York
Tyler is coming to get us now and then
we'll go to vaynermedia
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh speakers and thanks so much for
tuning have enough like those uh you
[ __ ] hack me bro well know anything I
can do for Judaism you know I'll try it
anyway
so and we were laughing I'm like when I
got the call and show I was like
floating my words my kids were asking me
for drinks and life my daughter was
coming in the room and I'm like just
trying to ask this question and so you
would like I said on the on the call I'm
like uh I need like ten seconds and and
I was talking to my son and you thought
I was talking to you and I was like no
worse this out but cool well listen I'm
super glad you guys are here I uh I
really hit it off with your teacher
professor here I mean like really I
couldn't wait for this day to happen so
I'm really happy you're here listen I'll
be honest like I can give you guys a
little context I don't you guys have any
idea who I am or anything about me okay
great so to be real honest I'd love to
maximize our time together answer [ __ ]
for you maybe I'll maybe I'll talk a
little bit just to create some framework
right but to me I'd love to just answer
any questions you guys might have or
things that nature here's my perspective
my big thing you know what caught my
attention about you talking about which
is I'm fascinated by the game of
opportunity right like I think when you
get into these conversations like who's
got opportunities born who wins the
lottery of being born into a trust fund
who doesn't you know who grows up in a
bad neighborhood who goes up but there's
people that live in the in the in the
Amazon like movie there's some there's a
lot going on with a seven point seven
billion people on earth to me the game
of opportunity is what's super
fascinating and I think the internet
just [ __ ] everything up in the best
way possible like there's just so much
more opportunity than there ever was
for the people that don't have the
opportunity and to me that's like [ __ ]
that's something you need to really wrap
your head around and I say that to
people that have everything handed to
them and people that have nothing handed
to them it's kind of agnostic now where
it gets real interesting for me with you
guys and I'm making presumptions based
on the five minutes we got the top but
what's really interesting to me is that
I grew up an immigrant I didn't have
much but and I was I grew up in a
different time than you guys are growing
up where school was the only way out
like the only way you could be
successful like when I was your age the
only thing I had ever heard is the only
way you could be successful is if you go
to Harvard and get a good job and they
said that there was no talk of
entrepreneurship there was no talk of
hustle flip and [ __ ] making sure that
nothing zero zero conversation and there
was definitely no internet so for me
what's really really crazy is I think
the people that have the advantage now
have the chip on their shoulder have the
flip mentality have the you know quick
score the salesmanship the stuff that I
associate more with not the Upper East
Side and I don't think people understand
that I don't think people really
understand that the DNA of the hustle
and the grind and the flip is actually
about to win way more now than the kids
that think they're going to go by the
books and go through the system and that
should be the greatest [ __ ] things
you've ever heard in your life if you
actually believe me so that's like my
energy that's why I wanted to have this
like if I get one of you [ __ ] kids to
actually believe me then this is ROI
positive for me then I'll get some good
email from you or like 15 years I'm like
yeah that was a good trip I'm really
glad you said that
it changed my mindset that's really what
I'm trying to get out of here and I wish
I think you guys know something about me
you don't know me I don't know you right
I wish you knew how much I believe that
how much I could give a [ __ ] to inspire
some kids I'm being really serious with
you I'm not checking a box to feel good
about myself
or do the right thing I just believe it
and I think if we ROI positive for me
because I actually think one of you is
going to hear me go do
[ __ ] and I want to do [ __ ] with me in 10
years and do business together so I just
really really want to make sure I set
the stage for this conversation I'm not
checking any boxes here other than being
selfish because I actually believe in
what I'm saying believe you guys
actually have the advantage that you
don't realize and just things that's
going to manifest and it's going to work
out for me in 15 or 20 years that's my
truth so and I think that's powerful
right like when I think about that I'm
like that's way cooler than like I want
to be a nice guy and help some school I
cup like nobody wants pandering right
who you want pandering like the number
one thing in life that I've fought my
whole life was handouts or like I went
into my dad's family liquor store
business when I can do I could have done
bigger things just to make sure I never
had it over my head that he did good by
me I needed to check that box and be
even with him so I'm visceral to like
anybody doing anything for me the only
thing I want to do for you here is to
wake you the [ __ ] up of how much
advantage you have against the market
because you got one of these then you're
in the game if you don't that's
different if you don't a smartphone then
I then I then I get quiet but if you do
you're in the game in a real way you
know you guys know this there's [ __ ]
kids [ __ ] flipping sneakers on
Instagram making more money than half
the [ __ ] people that work for me in
this company but are you willing to wake
up at 4:30 in the morning to be online
for two hours you know what to do we
know it just people aren't willing to
work so it's a binary game but it's real
it's so real it's crazy you know I was
odd odd I was on Breakfast Club and envy
called me out you see that yeah did I
saw up did you see the part where Emmys
like okay cool stop motivating give me
something real and I made as I go to the
dollar store and buy [ __ ] and fell on an
eBay like that whole thing it turned
into this whole thing I started this
video Amit called the 20-17 flip
challenge I'm getting the craziest
[ __ ] emails like just people that are
like I'm on welfare I make $5 an hour
like a
now I'm going to Marshalls and making
$1000 a week just real I just think
people aren't willing to work I think
it's much more fun to be mad at the
system my employees love to be mad at me
they love blaming me they love blaming
me they're like it's [ __ ] up cuz I'm
like no no here's what's actually
happening in the gah you know we uh we
fired 60 people because I felt the
company was getting fat and slow and so
I fired 60 people one guy that night
came up to me and he's like you said
we've hired people because you know
we're fat and slow and not working hard
enough like [ __ ] you like good
relationships ma'am you can see my vibe
right they feel comfortable saying [ __ ]
like that's me it literally was like
[ __ ] you like up me my team were working
[ __ ] 13 hours a day I said I know I
said the reason you're working 13 hours
a day is because you guys aren't getting
rid of the eight people on your team
that sucks [ __ ] because you're friends
with them so you know like that's just
the truth right so like to me here is
the truth in your situation makes it
make a lot of money and live whatever to
[ __ ] what life you want as long as
you got this because this is so
ridiculously powerful and nobody gives a
[ __ ] who you are on this you don't
impress anyone you know they're the
grades
only nothing I think that's powerful and
like whether that means you want a story
tell be in fashion flip stuff like
there's just there's just no excuse
anymore and I think it's liberating once
you actually believe in it when you
realize that nobody gets to decide your
[ __ ] [ __ ] gets real fun you know because
I'm empathetic like I'm empathetic man
like I get it like I don't really get it
because you got to live it they really
get it but I'm pretty close for the way
I look and I get it and it's just real
it's powerful so I just think there's
[ __ ] to be done and what's really
interesting is all my friends you know I
was a real bad student I went to a
college called Mount Ida college where
94% 96 % of the kids were African
American or Latino that's where I
probably got my permission add a little
swag right
and so that's that's where I spent my
four years on right and so like I met
kids
I've friends I mutt my sweet knee is in
jail and newer for rest of his life for
double murder
like I I slept with my wallet like it
was pretty [ __ ] up where I went to
college and and when I like I I when I
think about what those my friends my
friends the kids that were in my wedding
the opportunities they had cuz they
looked your part compared to what you
have it's [ __ ] crazy
it's crazy it's it some dude email me at
$11 when he heard the NB thing 11:00 to
make it a thousand dollars a month now
Marshalls and t.j.maxx he just listened
today downloaded the Amazon app instead
of playing mad at four hours a day he
goes to TJ Maxx and Marshalls and he
scans every [ __ ] product and with
first 11.11 first $11 he bought some
sort of shirt that was four dollars cost
and he sold it for 17 on eBay and he
built the whole thing it's crazy just
real yeah yeah download the Amazon app
you scan stuff you see what it costs
right I mean you don't actually pop
you're here tell us this tell me who you
are and what you're doing here well
actually not gary kubiak wake up with
Talan
I was my family came from Russia like a
sec parents day I was born and raised in
Brooklyn I school dropout all right okay
I came from Russia - yeah I'm just going
to pasta and I was 12 years old I still
drop out waste in my twenties for lunch
just chilling and doing nothing
productive five years ago I used to be
an attorney as possible living in milk
our specialities I had less than $11
when it started I was $100,000 in debt
of the IRS money most friends my
property perhaps five years doing Amazon
a gross of 40 million dollars in sales
last year
it's called [ __ ] progress there's a
lot of different business model they can
do one of them is retell arbitrary you
just go into stores and stand what they
have in swords you would have selling
for on Amazon eBay and there might be a
little profit you might find something
for ten so we're selling it on Amazon or
a favorite 20 there what people eat work
often for you and just say laughs you
get lucky right luck plays until you go
to dollar store they got some weird
thing by accident you buy for a dollar
it's going for eleven dollars from
sitting to buy 40 of them you look at
that up go but it's how you get oh it's
super hard hustle and also as well hey
guys go teach your backs buy something
take it home post it get it on Amazon or
Ebay ship it for four dollars because I
[ __ ] that right that's what people
thought that without realizing that once
you get your game tight yeah you can do
a scale you also start getting an eye
right like I just even look at the
jacket you're wearing I'm like okay get
this kid get like he should be going to
thrift stores using his eye buying [ __ ]
for two bucks and then marketing it on
Etsy for 29 as [ __ ] you know fashion
if I average profit on a night I was
robbing for five loss when you start out
let me start with oh yeah these five
years ago like what's the first [ __ ]
thing that's like world our salon and
salon is doing on Amazon with other
products that use day
new salon gave me a job I want more
thermo escaping the catalogues of did
during the wholesale suppliers that he
was going with and just doing garbage
I've seen what they're selling work or
no sailors whether summons or an Amazon
page is completely out the one percent
of items I made for box sidewalks and
you add that to your list and go from
one sailor days accepting sizes may
become to over a thousand sales go right
now and you know it's ports for five
bucks an item but when you do not scale
it adds up build awesome I saw I saw
something on your social like a first
you packed in your house then you had it
in your back yard
now you have a warehouse when I started
rented a little two-bedroom house that's
probably the size of this continent and
we're working out of that movie and my
boy have lines up hacking sessions got
my hands on all they were 12 14 15 hours
day and just skate on that just
component let me ask ya because we've
been one of these we're talking on the
way up here yeah have you do countably
watching I've been good I've YouTube
channel and I started DMing people yet
being like vegetables before like seeing
what you can do for others and so I
start sort of sliding into the DM oh uh
so I figure if I can get into a core
media you know cool okay so um so I
start setting on the MDL and true value
hardware store gets back you man I said
I'll wait I'll make you five free videos
and for me and my students and we have a
carpentry after-school program that I
just want to show you like this what
we're doing there product like you're
where we buy all of our supplies from
and you know let's let me try and do
something for you so they they emailed
me back and said yeah we want to try and
do a partnership with you and I have a
phone call set up for tomorrow that has
to do that so what what that means that
these guys is some of them like
music Elisha's in the fashion Wow and so
obviously not so like trying to sort of
like build a brand and then start DMing
people or one of the things we've been
talking about is why are we saying how
to kind of like Chronicle what you're
doing like um like recording the journey
because how amazing would that look at
Place Eminem had started when he was 12
and was writing rhymes and then like all
that footage exists but now unbelievable
to watch that the answer is yes oh right
like yes to all the [ __ ] you just said
you like like because you just
regurgitate in my [ __ ] think yeah I mean
look I think they should DM every single
every single music producer in the world
that they want to [ __ ] with and say look
we're starting out I'll come and [ __ ]
click Prince was a janitor you remember
when I said that I believe in that [ __ ]
so much [ __ ] Prince wanted it so bad
he [ __ ] cleaned up [ __ ] in exchange
for studio time and then he was good
enough they may get Metro boomin to like
let him clean up his [ __ ] and that's
where they are and they may not be good
enough so they would lose but it would
give them a chance but you can't you
can't do what every kid does which is
hit up these big-time producers and be
like yo my shit's fire listen to my [ __ ]
they get that $50,000 a day you need to
give people [ __ ] you you have your time
like every person's got something and
what you definitely have at this age is
you have time that's your asset your
time and what you do with it is what
you've got and so if you want to get
into music game I would hit up every
single person in the game DM them DMing
on Instagram is unstoppable
it is dumb move DM 20 30 people then T
get banned for a couple hours you start
again later right
and and you and you just hit up people
and be like like you could in turn for
the biggest fashion brand of all time
this summer you just have to ask 500 of
them and only ones gonna say kinda it's
a numbers game you know of course you we
talk a lot about self-awareness and
knowing yourself what does that mean for
young people that have had a hard life
or deal with a lot of different in which
kind of kids shouldn't deal with @fe so
I know somewhere has been like knowing
yourself but how do you like what are
your thoughts when you're trying to
figure out yourself and you have to kind
of deal with the baggage in your life
like you know I never hear you talk
about counseling or anything like that
something slaughtering I commit your
thoughts on more about self-awareness
look I think people that are growing up
in the best environments of all time are
struggling with self-awareness at 13 and
14
I mean 90% 90% of my company here in
their 30s and 40s and 20s have no clue
on self-awareness so here's what I would
say I would say that I'm a big fan of
just eating reality I'm just a fan of it
you know like like the reality was I was
never like my dad my dad I had my dad
but I didn't because he worked every our
number song
if every game instead of just insane
Rock Debbie are now is my rap now I was
happy it was way better knee leaving or
dying or you know it was great but like
I didn't have them I could have done
with my other friends who have
workaholic parents do and dwelled like
my dad's not in my baseball game or you
don't look I am NOT going to shortchange
the extremities of all the things you
know all the cliches parents drugs
murder mental health like all the things
the thing that I have not figured out is
how to get the universe to give a [ __ ]
so so to answer your question it's
amazing to see people in good situations
and bad situations go through a
situation and do this like if I could
give everybody a drug it would be
optimism right like and you're willing
to look at all your [ __ ] whatever it is
and by the way everybody thinks their
[ __ ] is the [ __ ] right like everybody's
like everyone like I said people sit in
this room one by one with me say well if
my dad didn't give me a hundred million
dollars I would have never been a loser
because it all came to easy to me
everybody thinks their ships the [ __ ]
cuz it's their life right people that
don't have parents I think they laugh at
that like [ __ ] you but that person
thinks that's the [ __ ] so it's about you
know I don't know we I don't talk about
a lot of things I don't know I don't
know how to recommend you know you know
counseling or how to build self
awareness or mental health I try to stay
away from things that I don't know
because I think that would be
detrimental to the things I do now what
I will say is you know self-aware so I
don't know how to teach self-awareness I
just know it's the most I just know it's
the game once you know who you are it
manifests into self-esteem you don't
actually then give a [ __ ] what you know
you sit here and just don't give a [ __ ]
what they say or any girl you just don't
care it's crazy when you get there
that's like the [ __ ] ultimate you're
just [ __ ] living life like in the
matrix you're just like running through
she to actually not give up especially
at this age that's what happened to me I
still think about it how [ __ ] did I not
give a [ __ ] right because it's like
Lincoln when you're like 13 14 15 like
your friend that's your whole life I
just remember not caring and I just I
was just on some different [ __ ] in my
head so that's what I want for everybody
because then you're [ __ ] set I don't
know man that's why it was hostile
that's why I don't talk about it right
like I just honestly I swear to God if I
know how to get there this whole thing
would be a wrap I don't know Jess I
don't know the world if I knew how to
like get there and get people there
right I try to get there by talking
about it and maybe somebody's like oh
[ __ ] that's kind of like me too let me
go deeper into that I actually do feel
like that actually don't give a [ __ ]
what I mean like I don't know but God
it's big because then peer pressure's
out then you're just not getting dragged
into anything you don't want to be doing
yeah
yeah please
what do you are exactly when you're
talking to online and trying to figure
out what their passion is and I know you
talked a lot about what your passion is
has been your plan right so in speaking
to our guys and they're like I don't
know what I want to do or you know I'm
not really into anything and what is
your voice listen I get that [ __ ] II I
wrote my first book was called how to
cash in on your passion which [ __ ] me
up because then everybody kept emailing
like what's my passion like I don't
[ __ ] know you like I don't look like
like I have no ideas the biggest thing
you realize is a lot of people don't
know or never find it or you know my
belief is the only answer for any of
them right for you for anybody is you
gotta figure out how to try [ __ ] like
that sea foam like like you just never
know what your favorite food was until
you try it you only had chicken you mana
not known that hot dogs were the best so
that's what I love about the internet
these kids have so much option to like
watch it on YouTube and for like my only
answer to me or anybody like it's just
like try [ __ ] and so like that's back to
opportunity easy to try [ __ ] when you
have hundreds of thousands of dollars in
the bank the parents that take you to
[ __ ] you got to hack the game right like
that's what's passionate for me about
this today this is me letting them try
[ __ ] here in a different way something
could happen who knows maybe not I'm
willing to go over nine but you try so
like that to me that's why I love the DM
thing right like you don't think 21
savages hit you back but do you mind
crazy [ __ ] happens people decide no
before they try you just decided no
because the system tells you know you've
been pound
you've been sold no and my weight not
just you the [ __ ] world
not tough situation the world everybody
saying now I just say yes and then if
it's a no I don't give a [ __ ] are you to
judge me that I lost I don't know what
you think and that's why I get so into
that because I'm then you're not scared
to try [ __ ] because when you don't give
a [ __ ] what anybody says about you
failing you love failing I love losing
it is crazy because you think I I love
it at it all the time that with him and
YouTube and a glowy partner on it don't
like I hate being on camera no clients
not my thing so he does not and I do a
lot of like social media itself and
anything like that in partnering with
him but you're thinking about
distribution it bums me when something
doesn't work for me to be great and and
it's an idea of loving the failure and
Hawaii I love getting punched in the
mouth I love it I love it I love it I
love it
what is it about the failures in that
long that you lover
I want it makes me want to stick it to
everybody who judged me when they judged
my fail well that's it
I like it I know I actually love it you
just kind of like it you know yeah or
that big yeah I get it I get it like for
me it's it's um yeah it's like it's a
chip on the shoulder I loved being an
underdog I loved being like from Russia
and not speaking English and like like
being small like somewhere around third
grade like [ __ ] I'm not going to be as
good at sports as these other kids are
getting real [ __ ] tall like you know
it's like you know like like I just
loved it and I still love it and it's
really funny now that I've made it in my
little space like I want to do other
[ __ ] cuz I don't want it like as soon as
I won the wine game I left because I
don't want to be the top dog I don't
want people trying to get me I want to
try to get then you know I love the
grind I love you know feel like that
that stuff is restrictive because like
when you like the top it's like there's
nowhere else to go it's not everybody is
ready to Mitchell when you always reach
up for the top it's like that car's
background I gotta tell you man and I'm
telling you my friend this this is the
operating system of the universe this is
the only thing that matters this is the
only thing that matters the attention on
this is the game and like patches and
everything like you could make an
Instagram account like go ahead good
like it's one kid I'm watching uh
musically you went from zero to hero in
four minutes five videos a prominent we
have like promoting our stuff like on
Instagram everyone is like China for
more yeah so like we're not getting hurt
because of this how do you avoid it you
don't avoid it you start doing different
[ __ ] you're doing what everybody else is
doing
let's put up a post he listened to me
and head up DM this hardware store
now something good happened you know
what I would do if I were you I would
hit up everybody who's making funny
videos and offer them free music it's
great man just guys you need exposure if
you get some booty girl to like twerk
behind your music because it could
happen like you just need people to hear
it right if you've got somebody like
Daquan or somebody like a funny account
who just uses your beat or use your song
at the background music to the clip
they're trying to put on but you have to
give here's the thing here's the thing
that I back to losing that I understood
when I was low nobody High gave a [ __ ]
so I wasn't going to people that were
high and said do something for me I was
going to people that were high and
saying this is what I'm gonna do for you
and that's why I try to get people into
that nobody gives a [ __ ] about your
problems mentality because then you
don't roll up on people asking or
thinking that nobody's going to put you
on just cuz they're gonna put you on
because I needed to be for their [ __ ]
you just gave them one
what else do you guys into like what
else is in your world like what else he
thing about yeah me personally clean
well you see me coming in high school
yeah I developer sometimes like contract
lien values to be like sneakers games
like design art so I'm like I'll really
go know like with direction to go
because I have so many talents
but it is like someone capability so I'm
just like right now just letting just
see was going know like I'm doing
opportunities I got be trying to singers
trying to cool it when I started trying
to a whole lot of stuff issues like are
you enjoying it actually like well
really enjoy I'm gonna miss with like
those people yeah so that's home village
argument too but like right now I really
don't no matter which maybe that's the
direction a lot of times I think the
doing is the direction right like like
three masters are happy is if it's going
good like if you're happy there's almost
nothing to say right like I think you
know I think taste when I hear that that
was just what I said earlier right like
try shed like if your mentor and and
sneakers I'm trying to start like you're
doing [ __ ] if you're actually doing it
to me the thing is I know kid frenemies
like who's had a similar thing I was
like cool and I like asked one more
question I realized he was doing it like
for 45 minutes a day but he had crazy
ambitions how many hours a day yeah you
know like that's the only way now you
got school and you got some other [ __ ]
you got to take care of but there's a
lot of time please you just went through
living it so you don't fail on your next
5 10 15 times out whatever you're not
going to get to that next
supplying the next block so if you could
stay in thinking about what am I gonna
do one like good Alice my passion and
interaction something to get nowhere but
if you say let me try this on the street
maybe it will be done with and you'll go
on to the next and on to the next and if
you look at the one thing like notice of
a certain level three from anyone
successful in anything whether it's a
business guy like Aaron or artists or
anyone anybody successful to work in a
lot in common is they've failed
99% of the time before they have a
historic or they have a business for
tory more important a destroyed up I
didn't fail a whole lot other than
school because I I knew that's what I
was not going to do it's just that
people don't realize that
LeBron [ __ ] took 4000 shots in a day
in fourth grade you know like like like
like what do you think they're doing
like yes listen you guys know isn't what
I saw him out items exactly and some of
these kids are athletic freaks but then
they were just smoking blunts all day
I was like oh that's why didn't they
make no now I understand they weren't
waking up at 5:30 in the morning running
[ __ ] hitting the gym and then
shooting for nine hours a day
well I like to throw the 50% of kids in
my suite 3:01 they're like I'm gonna be
a rapper like they didn't write all day
they never tried to get into studio like
they didn't do [ __ ] they talk [ __ ] God
do ponderin complaining clean it it's
one the same if you're dreaming or if
you're complaining to think [ __ ] means
you're just not doing [ __ ] well like one
warranty times is you know people do
look at the famous people whether it's a
celebrity or a poor person or a musician
and
they kind of hate on them like oh it's
easier oh it was this or that I'm
excuses and kind of hate on it people
look like talents real to like
serendipity happens like Lou Yanni
wasn't doing all that much work wrote a
couple songs in Arkansas stay in and wet
happiness it's not the norm but you know
I listen like this talent and work ethic
nothing else you can work 19 hours a day
on beats if you're not good enough
nothing good is gonna happen that's just
real which is why it's important try and
taste [ __ ] because you might be the
greatest [ __ ] cook of all time
you might it's crazy it's really [ __ ]
[ __ ] with me and it like like I'm
trying to figure it out myself out of
every I'm not Yoda you know like I'm
just trying to figure it out too but
like it's there man and the Internet
makes it crazy like you probably
wouldn't watch 700 videos of cooking you
know back in the day because whatever
played on cable played on cable right
but now you could write like video games
I'm trying to think back to my my days
up I'd like well there was some kid
where I could literally become
professional video game players that's
now real people getting paid millions to
play video games there's so much
opportunity because of the Internet
I'm doing of course meant yeah I mean I
was weird with that I was super in you
know back to not giving a [ __ ] it also
manifested the other way I didn't look
at anybody you know I looked up to my
parents you know they came to America
than $100 lived in a studio parlor with
eight family members and Queens you know
and I just watched them grind in my face
every day we bought nothing I went on
one family vacation my whole life
right we bought nothing you know Kmart
and Bradley's and like for clothes like
you know that's what we did my whole
life like my dad then eventually had a
little liquor store literally I wore
liquor t-shirts to school everyday my
life like you know so I I look up to
them you know how hard they brought it
and like they built the foundation right
I was lucky to have parents like that so
um but I never looked up like I want to
be like Bill Gates or I want to be like
Steve Jobs or I know I I want to be me
that's my best like I suck [ __ ] at so
much stuff my man like suck but I go so
hard at what I'm good at
and I'm gonna win the whole thing cuz of
it you know I watch it on video are you
saying that every day like it's us
I like to knock on effect so what was
this part it means you're like well out
there I'm grateful I'm driven by
gratitude and I wish everybody was like
I dunno ridiculously crazy it is that
you're a human being
400 trillion to one you're more likely
to win the lotto nine times in your life
and actually having a life honestly to
be very black-and-white on this I don't
know how we can't be thankful you could
have been tree
I just look at everything positive I got
a phone call right now my mom died
I'd be dead like dead like like I would
did right but then like very quickly I'd
be like I'm so grateful that I had her
and all this time we had you know what I
mean like I just I don't have it I'm
optimistic
I'm grateful like and and and I try to
impose that on people who have it more
than me and love less than me because
it's the same game it just you're gonna
choose how to look at life and I think
it's chemicals that make you say [ __ ] my
dad left me when I was four I'm in a bad
neighborhood my brother got killed like
like by just me kids who are the same
[ __ ] every day and like I look I said I
got to take the family on my back and
I'm going to do this and I'm gonna make
it to the league and that's you know
like it's just binary either you decided
[ __ ] or you decided to your advantage
what I know for facts is facts because
of this and Instagram and snapchat
YouTube people that have chips on their
shoulder the come from [ __ ] have the
advantage cuz the work ethic and the
hunger is now the biggest factor and
who's going to win and people like my
kids who have everything are soft I
think that's it I just I don't think my
kids want to work in a room half the
size of this for 16 hours a day because
they have a house in the Hamptons
they're just soft so it's crazy how
you'd never believe insane think you'd
believe it and then you think I'm saying
it for some [ __ ] so I don't say it
I'm gonna say it anyway I look and I'm
like these kids have the advantage they
don't get it I know they don't think it
and I'll never say it out loud because
the world would say [ __ ] you you're an
idiot how could how could you say that I
get it
I don't give a [ __ ] I know them right
and when you believe you know and when
you actually believe that she can get so
quickly you actually believe it and not
by the way I genuinely believe I had 900
kids walk through look just like you're
like 1 2 would actually 3 would actually
believe it not wanna believe because
they think I'm right not not believe it
because most people will not believe it
like actually believe it the whip that's
the winter ball teacher-directed lee you
see that in kids right so it's everyone
in this room duct tape for a reason
right I have 400 some very angry
students at school that we were leaving
to is like no I checked that dude out
how come you're not taking me around
oh is that right oh yeah like wait sad
walking um and so and so like you just
as a teacher often where we see like the
grapes up in kids and then to have them
like not see the same thing like them of
course come and you know this because
they go outside of your room and the
West the wolves tell them [ __ ] you yeah
and they believe the rest of the world
so that's gonna have my champion like
you
how many of these kids live even out
until relationships next may not be in
themselves what you saw on that four
years ago or two years ago or yeah I get
terrible his class I agree I just barely
passed and like this year and as close
as we got and like some of the words and
wisdom given me and not about music and
stuff like there it did just stick with
me forever
I think opportunities like this you have
no choice but to really believe it
myself and not just believe it because
you think somebody's right I'm here I
haven't you worked and somebody was very
important and successful and coming care
about whatever few examples and you see
stuff like gave people's opportunities I
have no choice but to believe this like
because you gotta understand what
happened to get you to this point it's
cool man [ __ ] real operatives it's
just experience as an opportunity what's
real cool for me guys is that back 20
years ago 25 years like everybody in
this circumstance wanted to be an
athlete or a rapper everybody and now
that entrepreneurship is getting cool
huge because it's super hard to win in
those games you have to actually win the
whole thing like you got to go all the
way there like you know that the 18,000
best basketball player on earth works at
UPS the 18,000 best entrepreneurs owns
ups
and that's why I'm going all-in that's
why I'm sitting here right now I want to
give back to the game you know you give
back to the game that gets you there
this entrepreneur thing I got D's and
F's I promise you straight up
I was worst student than everybody in
this room I was just non-existent
student like like when you said barely
passed I was laughing because I was like
my actually passed nothing they just
pushed me through because I was in
public school they're just like get the
[ __ ] out of here right now I to college
I was planning to not going to college
I'm just going to work in a liquor store
and build it up pay back my parents my
mom is like [ __ ] you you going to
college I'm like [ __ ] I'm like how the
[ __ ] am I going to college I'm like I'm
writing to 70 out of 273 in my class
right I got a 1.4 grade point average
and I can't put two sentences together
right I get a postcard in the mail form
a lie to college I fill out my name and
address and send it and I get a thing
back like you're in that's where I went
to college but what's crazy about that
is through self awareness through
recognizing the world was changing
through knowing what up who and what I
was the only reason I was so bad was I
was milking that time because that was
my last vacation I was milking high
school in college people always ask me
like you know when I talk like what are
you major in I'm like Madden you know
like like you know so I just that's why
self-awareness is cool like you know
when you really know yourself like how
much money
crazy to me how much money I leave on
the table because I love the game or I'd
rather spend the hour doing this that
once you know yourself and I've been
doing this my whole life
not after I made it I was paying myself
$30,000 a year building a big business
because I didn't need stuff the money is
not driving me the game a kid saying
coming to see something I was laughing
when he just said I'm coming to New York
and meeting a very important person I
like me and boring than funny-ass [ __ ]
you know like Lexington you know like
it's that's cool making an impact right
that's why you guys are creating on that
impact is crazy what I figured out is
[ __ ] I kind of both right I'm building
an empire and making an impact because
of the way it's all worked out
and now and now I'm getting greedy now
I'm penetrating hip-hop and sports so
that I can get my message out at scale
to you guys because I'm going to use
Kyle and logic you know and those guys
to get you know you know god I sure do
Kyle's running that office the other day
so let me ask you about somewhere just
over because I think one of the things
I'm always talking about how like
relationships are king to class or like
over content all the time
relationships have game elijah and
slowly you should go shake the hand of
every business owner in your
neighborhood it would change your life
one weekend will change your life why
because if they're running a business
that's not out of business they know
something they're doing something
productive and I'm again making
assumptions based on what you told me if
it's in tough neighborhoods and said
they're grinding you know yeah they got
stories they got scars sure and by the
way they would appreciate it
like when you're hustling you got your
corner badeah you got a barber shop
yours cut you get a young kid come
through and just say I just want to
shake your hand
Congrats on this business I'm proud of
you like they'll just be happy like and
then they may want to do something for
you
Carla's practical doing the right thing
is always the right thing that's why of
course cuz if you all didn't just shake
some guy's hand and that guy's like
that's memorable and he lives a couple
blocks away and then something happens
and I'm like for some reason Calvin
Klein is the boss of like like she got
how [ __ ] works
putting that's how the world works
that's why and it's just it's a nice
thing to do
I just think those business owners would
appreciate it you never know when that
may stumble into something next you know
you do it
persons caught off guard because it's
weird like who the [ __ ] does that right
so they don't even really react you
leave but then a week later you're
walking by with your boys like hey they
grab you and they're like tell me later
something like we love to do music
they're like my cousin owns a studio you
want some free time offer thank you so I
guess when they opossums act when they
pop and they put you on yeah so what did
you what did you realize itself
awareness was important because I think
that's something I talk about in class a
lot the importance of that and I think
it scares the idea that like you're
going to admit that like there are
things that will not do that and when I
got it when I just when I got into the
business world and started spending a
lot of time very closely with people and
then would let hear them talk and go oh
[ __ ] like they're wrong about themselves
I didn't know I had I didn't know if I
knew the word but it became like
delusional or somebody who I would come
like somebody who's a hypocrite drives
me crazy it scares the [ __ ] visceral to
it so which is why like when I say [ __ ]
like when you call in my show and I'm
like you're coming I laugh because I
always think the other person always
thinks like is this really gonna happen
you know so like to me like everybody's
so used to people letting them down and
this event so anyway when did I first
learn it when I was like got to really
know people in business and life as a
kid in college it didn't mean anything
to me that was like life but when I got
into business and to be like I can do
that like know what you think but like
it started getting weird to me that
people are so confused about what they
were good at what they were bad at
because now I was in the zone of me just
doing me and I just like I just I stay
my lane like real [ __ ] tight like I
know what I am I know what I wish I was
we all wish we were something so that's
when it started becoming
lines themselves about who they are how
do you how do you really start figuring
out who you want it like you as a person
yeah so um for these guys think these
guys are like you know I hear 90 percent
of dudes I talk to either one to be a
rapper or a football player have to play
are you on the football team no no no
not just go out next year it's like but
like I don't know how you know look look
my move and you know this because you
watch Mike on and I don't know if you
have the air cover
to do this move the only thing that I've
ever seen work is when he says now not
this show I'm going out next I'm like
you're [ __ ] full of [ __ ] you [ __ ]
suck good by the way that's the only
thing the only thing that works is
suffocating people put up put them on
full-blast
hell yeah so we're here for all right so
you know how you you know you boast
about having on the technology and
everything so I'm saying now I won't
hack do things that you know people say
in my head you like to do drugs or like
go out there in the street do whatever
because we got so much this we can make
the board we can make more money doing
you know flipping simple stuff and just
you know going on yeah
so like
so he would just take any steps like
it's going to take like maybe a hundred
pounds but you'll probably get it sooner
or later my belief is that if you're a
great drug dealer you'd be a great
businessman I just believe that because
it's the same game you're selling your
work in it like like listen that's the
only friends I had were drug dealers
like like like if you're good at that
I'm saying you know there's a lot of
drug dealers that suck at it right like
right right right
like listen I mean like all the kids
that I really hung on to and friendships
I'm like look in the man loose he's
breaking down these bags and some
nickels because he's making more money
that way
and he's chanting he's actually making
$3 bags but he realized that everybody
at the school doesn't know the [ __ ]
difference doesn't care he's smart and I
would see other people who like buyer
accounts and like [ __ ] smoke
three-fourths of it in four minutes and
then like be bad at flipping in I was
like he's a [ __ ] loser so if you're
good at it or if somebody if somebody's
good at it they'd be even better at
flipping sneakers or gear or go into the
thrift store and flipping because it's
the same [ __ ] move and then when you
have the freedom of being not scared to
get caught now you're [ __ ] moving
fast because when you're selling drugs
you got to think about that extra
dimension of getting caught but when
you're selling [ __ ] t-shirts now
you're a [ __ ] entrepreneur and
everybody think you know like people put
you on a pedestal so yes I believe that
hello hello
I believe it cause it's true because
it's [ __ ] true because the kids that
I knew that sold drugs for real and were
real good at it have gone on to be much
more successful in the world than the
ones that did it like it's just hustle
it's you've got people skills
you see angles that's the same [ __ ]
that's like [ __ ] this thrift store keeps
getting their [ __ ] merchandise and
they put it out at 9:30 in the morning
I'm gonna go there because there might
be some Nikes it's just hard work I
think every like when you realize how
much more money you can make how much
like how much good can happen from hard
work everybody's willing to put in the
hook if I prize if I was a real genie or
a real [ __ ] Yoda and I thought I was
like yo check this out watch it and you
saw you your [ __ ] what the [ __ ] and you
show you and it's like a good life and
I'm like yo you got to do you got to
work 15 hours a day right now for next
10 years straight you'll do it everybody
will do it people don't do it because
they're not sure what's on the other
side of it because they said no before
they said yes so the question is how do
you avoid and I had good parenting
that's a truth my mom instilled so much
self-esteem in me I thought it was
Superman that's the truth I thought it
was the best
now whether my mom did that or was my
natural chemicals or like I predicted
the future I just thought it was the
best and once you think you're the best
you don't get who the [ __ ] are you to
say that I'm black or you know like I'm
stupid or I'm nerd out your [ __ ] I'll
see you at the finish line partner you
know like that that was my mentality
that was my mentality like I'm real glad
that high school is going to be the
highlight of your [ __ ] life like you
better really really really enjoy these
48 months because you're gonna [ __ ]
suck in life that's how I thought I was
competitive about it if anybody came out
what's crazy is what's really
interesting is nobody really came at
like like like when something is when
you're nice and you're not bothering
anybody and you're just in your own [ __ ]
and you're nice not even long you're
quiet but you're like in your own
shipping knife okay you know you're nice
to everybody like nobody real mad at you
that I think rank I didn't like people
who might make a joke here and there but
didn't have real juice behind it you
know nobody really bothered me you know
but listen I have to be like bit listen
I have no idea where you guys are from
but I have some friends from some [ __ ]
up places where it was
that easy like when you were 12 and 13
you were getting recruited to do some
[ __ ] and it wasn't as easy to just be
like I'm doing my own thing so I listen
I'm always careful and I don't know the
back stories or every detail so I could
do it
I wasn't recruited to do some [ __ ]
crazy [ __ ]
you know if you're lucky enough to not
being recruited by local gangs to do
[ __ ] well then you have no excuses
because my big thing is like you're
either going to you're going to define
yourself for yourself or you're going to
let somebody else to find you you're
thinking like your mom define you your
dad defined your grandparents to find
your older brother your older sister
dude from around the way
you know you somebody's going to define
you or you're going to define yourself
I'm just trying to figure out how to
hack at you to make you define yourself
for yourself in yourself within yourself
and then then [ __ ] changes Jelena how do
you keep the motivation keep writing and
working hard or those I have no choice
there's no choice well when you have
multiple things because I'm trying to
because I don't think I'm anything yet
man if I told you what was in my head
you would not believe me
in terms of greatness
touch me yeah like I'm not I'm not you
know not naive I know I've made a lot of
money
I'm started make an impact but like I
don't I don't read my own press
clippings I wasn't joking when I was
laughing when you said an important
person like I mean it that wasn't for
show that's just what goes through my
body
I believe it like I believe it like my
ambition is as great as it gets I think
I can go down all-time if I can stay
alive and like I cuz I know I want to do
good and be great like I want to be
great I can do both I'm weird I can do
both the reason I can be good for people
is I'm so good at my craft I can put 80%
of my energy against it and achieve more
than everybody else which leaves me so
much room to do other [ __ ] which will
deal what I want and then you heard this
I think you know what I really am doing
here I'm trying to suck
wanted you to come to my funeral
that's my jam my man if I said something
here that [ __ ] triggered a different
chemical in your brain and you went on
to have a great life and I think I'm
going to be pretty damn famous by the
time I die and you hear I'm dead you
might be like I should probably go to
that man Tina he changed my life
you take your kid and tell them the
story that's cool my grandkids get to
see you from you know Texas to come to
my funeral in New York and telling
stories of how I change your life that's
the greatest legacy of all time and
there's only one way to do that you
gotta give what's the moment I found
this no problem I also the goal of life
somebody's trauma when it was by my
girlfriend intercom thank God it said at
the time otherwise you would be mom Anna
of course I'm glad your hair
I'll get to her I'll get to her yes talk
about romance with you guys about you
know you thought about not being number
one like it's not always about being
number one you know I think you need to
I think you should strive to be number
one and be realistic if you're number
fourteen thousand like you got to try
sure my bad no and I think you know it's
funny I think I threw that in there when
I talked earlier about being the
18-thousand best entrepreneur it's you
know it's yeah I think that's right I
think that's right
ah and I think where you're going and I
believe in this which is too many people
trying to be number one and then if not
they want to be zero like it's like this
all or nothing game it's just a false
game it's not it's not practical it's
not real life so listen I'm really glad
you guys came through we can do this
again you know everybody's got their own
style a lot of people some people ask
questions other people are a little more
quiet you can hit me up on DM just make
sure you start it because you only see
the first couple words make sure you
start that you're part of this crew I
know that not everybody wants to share
their [ __ ] out loud but I'm thrilled to
bring anybody in this room
you can I I realized you try and get our
guy self tolerant I have selfish
question because I didn't call me um I'm
trying to build my youtube channel I'm
so I'm doing I'm trying to do every
single thing that I do are you saying
there's only one answer collaborations
alright that's it
hit up just like everybody else every
single every single YouTube celebrity
that lives in Philadelphia should hear
from you have them come through the
school let's go do trick shots in the
[ __ ] courtyard with them whatever
takes siphon audience from them you're
now going to put this video up it's
gonna have my name in it my name gets
searched on YouTube trillions of times
in the eternity one of the right people
looks at it from for years now and away
you go
yeah we got this I like to get people
pictures of my own space oh my god I
love that and just the same thing
I appreciate it please comment good luck
to ya my yeah of course my mom I'll do
better than that you know what let come
with me in my office I'll let them sign
up I'll sign you guys all a book
[Music]